[Musique]
du
m
bien sûr la région qui est rude on ne
peut pas de jolies comme ça lui arrive
22e à les tables il en allait vous
occuper tout quoi et bien sûr pourtant
c'est ce à quoi il traîne avec ses
copains comme ça non mais sérieux quoi
vous êtes là bonjour excusez moi je
parlais à mon ami giat rude une fois on
compte elle n'est pas très très très
contente bref bonjour la réunion pour le
monde comment il est là écoute moi ça va
très bien aujourd'hui nous a monté de la
plaine des cafres on a pris de direction
notre dame de la paix pour arriver dans
cet endroit magnifique ans j'ai
rencontré ma copine alors on va
aujourd'hui vous parler de petits sablés
des petits bobos et de crème de cannes
nîmes avec trend de cannes c'est juste
horrible
or moi je vous propose de me suivre
allez salut à tout à l'heure après pas
cassé niary tally là allez venez avec
moi
on y va
[Musique]
j'ai toujours une date à eau et aux
élections
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui faut chaud bonjour comment ils le
savent assez bien et au mal à deux
questions est-ce que je peux l'appeler
par son prénom avec plaisir commence
voilà oui
clémence penser deuxième question c'est
quoi cette bonne odeur kimouche que nous
surtout en ariège
ah ça c'est les bons petits sablés aux
douaniers que france à français à
l'émission commence bien tu sais comment
parler aux étoiles avec levante à la fin
du mois un petit peu ou s'annulent et là
on est à la peine les cas nous notre
activité c'est la confiserie confiture
confiserie sadi a foncé tout les
confitures réunionnais tamarins vous y
aviez letchis ananas papaye et plusieurs
d'autres encore et plus on sait aussi
des biscuits mais biscuits gingembre que
puma fonds bat bat coco et petits sablés
au goyavier ont fait des sirops ont fait
des piments avait des piments chouchou
qui m'ont bab afsi jacques mangold
enfin on fait un petit peu de tout il
faut avoir vu la variété pour le client
comme si la moi personnellement ma
bougie salive déjà
ben écoute allons voir ça ou moto m'a
d'ailleurs allé à laon niveau mais avant
il faut mettre un petit charles matin on
va mettre la charlotte
allez messieurs voilà de nouveau
[Musique]
c'est l'endroit où officie à côté c'est
l'endroit confie tu as tu sais quoi
mais me suivre à nouveau parler la
abbaoui vous en parlera mieux parce que
c'est lui qui fixe pensé à tout de suite
avant de partir dans les cultures tour
fillon dieu lumière
ma mère tue beaucoup monsieur jours
après m'avoir donné embauche à tour dix
mois un petit peu ce que tu es en train
de faire donc assez des sablés aux goyas
lier des sables vous avez oui c'est une
recette que j'ai ramené d'al saloum il
en alsace on fait ça avec du lâcher les
groseilles nom est ici bon j'ai pensé
pouvoir le faire avec du goyavier et 10
mois le goyavier que tu que tu mets là
dedans il y à 12 mars c'est parce que
c'est un produit local aussi oui tout et
tout locaux chez nous le goyavier vient
de la plaine des palmistes et pour après
les fruits c'est les ananas il vient de
l'est
d'accord l'ebit pas si bien de la plaine
des cafres après y'a bon ya tout plein
de produits différents producteurs
d'accord consommation sans poisson local
sellami un moment est mis en cause comme
ça et tu dis moi un petit peu et donc je
vois que tu fais tu as passé s'est fait
en deux parties placer le fond nous
avons effacé le dessus après ça ça va
être mis dans les rues
voilà il faut que ça soit à peu près la
même épaisseur
après on est on est on dans le four et
une fois cuit il faut faire ça
rapidement parce qu'il faut faire ça
chauffe ça promet on étale sur la grille
mais il n'a pas de goyavier dessus et on
remet le chapeau par monsieur bricolage
le cuir avant voilà on lui tombe de la
pâte
las vegas entre applis sont déroulés à
la gauche est soleil du ponant les
bruits de trésorerie pour moi laisse
donc la la la
et c'est la pub de goya diront qui est
cuit avec du sucre
après on met ça aux frais un peu comme
la confiture
voilà ce qu'ont à configurer voilà et
donc là donc ça sert et les bonbons fini
et sa gouaille à l'équipe dans le bon
tempo veut goûter avec mes contrats
voyons mais bien sûr que oui
alors moi mais vous de ça comme ça en
direct de 11h ou de la savoie au diamant
veut laisser décoller même du peuple
voilà les rangs pécho oui car c'est
froid ça colle le dessus et reste bien
cool c'est bon c'est bon et c'est bon
donc vous êtes brune dernier saut
et on m'a dit aussi que tu suis plus
spécialiste de la traîne de cannes dont
il a donné la recette de suite nordique
non si c'est une recette que j'ai
inventé et je ne la donne pas pourquoi
je suis plus tu m'en aller souper
donc je donnerais pas demain après
demain entre quatre yeux
non mais je comprends tout à fait
sérieusement
alors explique moi un petit peu
paresseux cette idée de trême de cannes
votre moi c'était la première ordonnance
au départ les j'ai inventé ce produit et
je dis bon va essayer de faire un
produit typique réunionnais avec du
sirop la cuite et après j'ai commencé à
faire ce produit là bon il m'a fallu du
temps il m'a fallu presque un an pour
arriver au top niveau
parce que moi je fais tout à 100% par 99
points il faut que ça soit fait à 100%
et j'ai réussi après un an j'ai failli
arrêter entre temps clément selma m'a
quand même encouragée elle a dit arrête
pendant pendant deux trois jours et j'ai
repris et j'ai réussi mon produit
je suis fier de ma femme aussi qu'elle
ans qui m'a qui m'a boosté qui m'a
remonté
voilà mes dix mois qu'est ce que tu fais
avec sur les la crème de carnassiers
qu'on peut le mettre sur différents
produits
voilà on peut en faire avec des sables
et sans les sables et après sur les
crêpes des gaufres la glace comme on a
différents parfums sur les sur les
yaourts 100 milliards nature je dis
bravo parce que déjà aussi l'idée de ce
mélange petits sablés d'alsace avec des
produits bien sans poisson nuée
d'oiseaux à la bouche
bah oui allez moi je un bon allez à tout
à l'heure
d'accord on un jour de clémence
la plupart
alors j'ai vu que tu es mis un petit
équipe lundi tabler sur la table ah oui
aussi puisqu'il ya là dedans alors là où
naquit le climat coco gingembre combat
bas et sablé goya libye ne serait ce pas
cette fameuse crème de cannes alors tu
sais quoi je pose une petite question
oui je veux goûter un la crème
depuis laquelle je t'écoute et quand
même mais je voulais un petit peu de
crème en même temps alemao
dis moi comment vous avez débuté cette
activité il ya dix ans premier arrivé
ici et au début on voulait faire un peu
de restauration parce que mon arrivée
cuisinier de formation en cuisine et
pâtissiers alors on a commencé à faire
des confitures et c'est de là qu'on n'a
vu que les confitures et ça marche et
c'était agréable
donc on a continué la confiture et après
on a mis au point la crème de canne à
sucre pour moi mon idiot d'autres
communes
c'est un truc de fou un petit goût mais
bon ça c'est drôle alors d'autant plus
que même pas trop sucré n'a plutôt salée
et là je crois que tu fais pas mon
tempérament changer diamant où les cieux
que l'on pense pas à l'expo à bon marché
enfin ne dit pas tout non mais nous
pensons à l'espoir d'une un quelqu'un
que les en métropole là bas et que il
prend les produits avec nous et il fait
goûter dans les grandes épiceries et
tout ça ben nous on aura certainement de
bonnes commandes dans les mois à venir
et puis la gelée au rhum aussi c'est un
prodige par aussi que nous fait depuis
que nous l'arrivée à la réunion c'est
nous la mettons en place ce jeu léo rome
là et ça au moins ça sur le foie gras
sur le magret de canon sur le bois sont
fumés base oreilles aime bien parce
qu'avoir une chronologie
moi même manière face à lui mais sans
aucune retenue ni au revoir madame
petits sablés quand même intérêt or tout
envoi la bluezero revoir et puis l'on
revoie nous très vite des crèmes en
effet un petit ouattara a gagné
dévalisent les bocaux et l'hébreu bon
elle n'aura pour rire vos autres pour la
peine
voilà ça n'a pas mis trop de temps à la
prochaine mais si beaucoup de
t'accueille et bravo on compose
introduit merci c'est gentil
[Musique]
voilà l'émission se termine mais je ne
vous laisse pas comme ça je vous laisse
à votre magnifique du grand bénare piton
des neiges
ici c'est chez nous marmaille oui oui
oui île de la réunion
alors je vous dis au revoir à la
prochaine émission et surtout je vais
finir mes petits sablés et surtout on
n'est pas des lauder je n'ai pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout on
n'en sort pas on ne sent pas une ombre
[Musique]